let's bring in Michael McCann he's the
Sports Illustrated legal analyst Mike
can you help us with this on what is
surgery and what is a procedure I think
anytime a doctor does nothing to you
with instruments
that's a surgery in my book all right
well thank you Michael that's all we
wanted you to help us with we appreciate
it thank you help us understand fact
from fiction here on what happened with
the NCAA claiming it delivered on a
promise and may profound and meaningful
changes to college basketball in
response to last year's federal
indictments within the sport so what it
exactly happened yesterday as we move
forward
they are profound changes in the sense
that we're going to see sports agents
directly involved with NCAA sports and
that is a big change we know for years
the n-c-double-a has been very skeptical
dubious of sports agents and now at
least for a certain caliber of
basketball players in college they will
be able to retain the services of a
sports agent plus if the NBA and Players
Association agree to change the age
limit in the NBA then high school
seniors who meet certain criteria will
be able to get an agent as well so this
is really this is a fundamental shift
for the NCAA in terms of allowing sports
agents although in very narrow
categories it's not by any means
everyone gets a sports agent and and
everyone doesn't include football
players either well what I don't
understand here is they're saying to us
a basketball hey you guys decide who's
elite us a basketball says no we're not
in we don't want to be involved in this
but the NCAA goes ahead and says hey
look at the changes we've made meanwhile
the NBA and USA basketball are going
wingmen you're blindsiding us we didn't
know that you were going to actually go
to print with this yeah I mean one
concern for the n-c-double-a is that it
doesn't want to appear as if it's
conspiring with USA basketball are
conspiring with the NBA because once it
starts to do that there's the
possibility of an antitrust claim that
these are in some ways competing
entities that could have joined hands to
agree on rules that impact players so
you know it to defend the n-c-double-a
on this point it actually makes sense
to say we're not involved with who gets
counted as a qualified player that it's
some third party which with which we
have no relationship so the n-c-double-a
could be arguing at least implicitly
they want separation from this
distinction yeah I think it's a whole
lot of nothing here Michael maybe you
know you're seeing it through a legal
prism and I'm just looking at this with
just what reality is elite players are
already they already have representation
you know I you know and who's deciding
who's elite I imagine if you there's a
chance you're gonna be drafted then you
should be considered lead if they're
only saying like 15 kids can be elite I
get I know they want to get rid of
agents or at least control agents and
they want to try to soften AAU or water
it down or take it away I don't know if
I see much of anything here Michael well
this could also just be the first step
right Ivy I think we're gonna see
complaints by football players and also
potentially women basketball players and
other athletes that can turn pro who
could bring a variety of legal claims if
they wanted to go in that direction
arguing that they're being denied a
benefit that an elite group of male
basketball players can get so if that's
the case and the NCAA feels pressured I
think we could see a more fundamental
shift where agents are allowed more
generally and and I think you know I
agree with you Dan that this isn't a big
change in that these agents are going to
be restricted from negotiating
endorsement deals on behalf of players
that would be a big change or allowing
players to monetize their name image and
likeness through having a YouTube
channel or other means those are not
part of this deal but if this is the
first step of a longer sequence of
events for the n-c-double-a I do think
it could prove meaningful we're talking
to Michael McCann a legal expert at
Sports Illustrated but is this just
another way of ensuring that the NCAA is
not going to be paying its athletes yeah
I think this is like the n-c-double-a
often does it it takes interim steps as
a way of trying to push back pressures
on the n-c-double-a to pay athletes that
whether it's allowing players to get the
full cost of attendance which
really was a reflection of ed O'Bannon's
case where O'Bannon sued and then the
NCAA made that shift and I think the
NCAA is an entity where when it gets
sued or when it gets called to the table
it does cede certain things but it wants
to hold on to this fundamental idea of
amateurism this fundamental idea of the
student-athletes that are that remain
very controversial so yeah I do think
this is a response by the n-c-double-a
to sort of push back some of the the
larger pressures against it but at the
end of the day the n-c-double-a can only
hold on as long as the market lets it
and if conferences continue to become
more and more autonomous and continue to
do their own TV deals I think we're
gonna see a lot of conferences say why
do we need the NCW why does the SEC need
it couldn't they just have make up their
own rules Michael thank you I appreciate
your time as always thank you that's
Michael McCann legal expert at Sports
Illustrated for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]